I parted my hair down the middle and I
don't know if I like it okay okay okay
just keep saying okay that'll make it
better okay
it is Tuesday here on its grace and you
don't know what that means do you I have
an idea sort of fleshed out in my brain
I'm a cannibal flesh and so we're gonna
kind of get through this together
because I haven't totally figured this
out so let's see what happens it's a
brand new year and I usually used my
Tuesday's before to haze all of you guys
and comment on your comments and this
year I want to be nicer to all of you so
instead of you've been hazed
it's you've embraced I know this subtle
you spell it but it out cool kids spell
it the cool kids that smoke cigarettes
Billy don't don't smoke cigarettes so
instead of commenting on your comments I
will be vomiting on your comments you'll
find out what that means like real vomit
this idea might not stick or it might be
super sticky I don't know it depends
what I've eaten we're gonna start with
Twitter
I feel immobilized can't spell
immobilize without mom oh-ha reject yeah
what do I say here new person new person
new person what should I stay here it's
a new year so let's do everything
different new new nude new where's the
new person new person for all of you
that don't know when a new person
comments on one of my
videos I praise the person to welcome
them to the it grace
family aha Bridget's a more like aha
Bridget you are very good at discovering
things oh it's good thing that you were
born with no fingers than just this one
finger that points up so every
expression of your hand is as if you've
just discovered something you've been
break you see the vomiting on your
comments I just wanna grace all week to
recognize my existence too much okay
okay you've been recognized
uh-oh you and I just traveled to a
vortex Shay braiding new person to
person to person shade waving more like
Shay is excellent at branding horse hair
Yoga praise it's great guys it's grace
ah guess who's back you get it
grace facts new person new person to
person
grace backs more like grace Schatz not a
lot because she's in control of her vows
good for her you give a British
congratulations on Forbes and reaching
500 K followers guys I was put on the
Forbes 30 under 30 list with just insane
but also now an achievement that my
parents can understand and I passed 500
thousand subscribers on Twitter and do
numbers matter I don't know it does
matter because I'm 28 and that's why I
was on the 30 under 30 list but like
brace facts anyway a Twitter account for
facts about me how I'm interested to see
how true these facts are now let's go to
yeah a little bit cuz I don't have a
Facebook set up yet sorry y'all Jamie
Oliver new person person your person
what Jamie Oliver more like and Jamie
I'll have you over to have cook me
dinner because you are good at that and
I would like food in my mouth from you
just stop your report come on grace show
us what you got big love probably they
don't know what Jamie Oliver is a
celebrity chef and I used to watch his
show The Naked Chef and he would get on
its little moped and he would go to the
market and get fresh ingredients and he
would come home and he would chop them
up on a cutting board that looked like a
tree stump
[Music]
so that's cool
ktg etc new person to person to person
ktg etc more like yes there is plenty
more to go on with you because you are
endlessly good at talking about
everything that the world has to offer
and sometimes even when it doesn't have
an offer you talk a lot but that's great
your approach you fight the unspecified
and big power grace fight it I do
everyday gravity whatever vomiting on
your comments today guys thank you all
for being here this is just too much for
me to handle and I'm just going to not
communicate my I don't know remember
that's how we get these videos down this
is my idea book let's look at some ideas
great idea
we're gonna do a great use of paper when
all of the other papers are used yep
excellent excellent use of notebook